Hey Bill,
I'm Haitian.
I'm an eighth grader at Joel peanuts in
middle school and I was wondering why do
people have favorites if our brains
offers you really grow the same,
shouldn't we all have the same
favorites?
Aren't we all the same donor?
Our brains all grow the same.
The answer is no and yes it is to say we
have much more like a,
we are much more alike than we are
different.
This old question,
if I see red,
is it the same to you as it is to me?
Like what I think is red is really green
and your brain just learns to call what
you're a green is my red and so on.
Okay.
These are good questions but I think the
reason we have favorites is that we all
are slightly different.
We do not look identical.
We are not biological clones.
Everybody is a little different.
Everybody is exposed to different
experiences and different chemicals,
different things in the air and water as
you grow up.
So what you prefer and food,
uh,
could change from one place to another
based on your environment.
And everybody's genes are different.
The read.
One exception might be identical twins,
but everybody's genes are different.
And so what we prefer,
what we like,
what we find is favorites is different
from one person to another,
but if nothing else I have learned in
life,
people are a heck of a lot more alike
than they are different.
You'll find that if you like a yummy
chocolate dessert,
it's very likely that someone else will
like that yummy chocolate dessert that
your favorites you'll be,
you may be surprised are favored by a
great many people.
When you get into
disagreements,
it's often I think a result of your
experiences.
Like I've had great experiences eating
ice cream with honey,
vanilla ice cream with honey.
Every time I think about it,
I think about my dad and I have good
thoughts,
but there's other people who think
vanilla ice cream.
That's not an interesting enough to me,
honey.
That's too commonplace.
No,
I won't say I feel bad for you,
but that means more vanilla and honey
for me.
Uh,
that's a,
you'll find people more alike than they
are different and enjoy the favorite.
Celebrate these little differences.
That's part of what makes life fun.
Carry on.